[Musik]
und damit einen schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum heute-journal
das getreideabkommen einseitig
aufgekündigt dafür dass bombardieren von
Schiffen die kennen Ukraine fahren
angekündigt und den Hafen von Odessa
bereits unter Beschuss genommen
russlandsverhalten allein in den letzten
Tagen dürfte den EU-Außenminister und
Ministerinnen die sich heute in Brüssel
trafen jede Menge Gesprächsstoff
geliefert haben und eines war ein klar
es besteht handlungs- und
Verhandlungsbedarf mit dem der das
Abkommen aufgekündigt hat nämlich Putin
und mit dem der ist eingefädelt hatte
Erdogan da kann ein freier Kopf nicht
wirklich schaden
ein kurzer Blick Außenministerin bärburg
vor dem Gipfel es wird ein Tag werden
wieder einmal im Zeichen des Ukraine
Krieges
dann der Auftritt ganz diplomatisch mit
einer Botschaft geprägt von der
dramatischen Lage der Welt droht Hunger
weil Russland die Getreide Silos der
Ukraine zerstört
100.000 von Menschen um nicht zu sagen
Millionen brauchen dringend das Getreide
aus der Ukraine deswegen arbeiten wir
mit allen Partnern international
zusammen damit das Getreide in der
Ukraine jetzt in den nächsten Wochen
nicht in den Silos verrottet und da
kommt er ins Spiel der wiedergewählte
türkische Präsident Erdogan er ist einer
der wenigen der eine Beziehung zum
russischen Präsidenten Putin fliegt auch
wenn das Verhältnis zum Russen
schwieriger wird hofft die EU darauf
dass Erdogan vielleicht vermitteln kann
die Türkei ich glaube das einzige Land
hier was ich sehe was einen Einfluss auf
Putin hat um dieses getreideabkommen was
ja die ganze Welt betrifft wieder
zustande zu bringen ein Erdogan macht
nichts umsonst er hat seinen Wählern den
Aufschwung versprochen nun braucht er
Geld deshalb entdeckt er neue alte
Beziehungen wieder deshalb schaut er
wieder nach Europa
ist für die türkische Wirtschaft
unverzichtbar die Türkei ist ein Land
das Waren produziert um sie zu verkaufen
braucht sie den europäischen Markt
denn in der Türkei herrscht eine
Wirtschaftskrise fast 100 Prozent
Inflation so inoffizielle Schätzungen
erlebt das Land 4 Euro sollen zwei
Auberginen Kosten jeden Tag steigen die
Preise auf dem Markt in Istanbul können
wir uns nicht auf 3,30 € einigen alles
wird teurer ich habe nicht mehr
siemens ist Rentnerin wie viele andere
kann sie die Preise nicht mehr zahlen
ich habe früher nie gehandelt er dagegen
schon immer Politik als Basar sein
Geschäft auf dem NATO-Gipfel hat Erdogan
seine Zustimmung für den Beitritt
Schwedens zur Militärbündnis an engere
Beziehungen mit Europa geknüpft viele in
Brüssel hat das überrascht
die Türkei will wieder mit uns über
einen Beitritt verhandeln sie wollen die
Türkisch europäischen Beziehungen wieder
auf die Tagesordnung hießen das sind
gute Nachrichten
aber sind die guten Nachrichten auch
realistisch die außenministerinnen und
Außenminister jedenfalls sehen
Beitrittsverhandlungen skeptisch das
liegt daran dass wesentliche Kapitel die
für diese Gespräche essentiell sind wie
Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Menschenrechtsschutz eben nicht nur
nicht umgesetzt worden sind sondern weit
von dem entfernt sind
Erdogan braucht Europas Geld und Europa
braucht Erdogans Hilfe eine alte
toxische Beziehung die wieder auflegt
ja auch weil Erdogan wir haben es gerade
im Stück von ultra gehört seinen Draht
zum russischen Präsidenten pflegt
Erdogan war es ja auch der das
getreideabkommen eingefädelt hatte jetzt
hat Putin ist aufgekündigt war vor
weiteren Getreide Exporten auch das war
heute Abend beim Treffen der
EU-Außenminister Thema Ulf die EU will
deshalb die Ukraine bei der Suche nach
sagen wir mal Alternativen
Transportwegen unterstützen mit der Bahn
mit Binnenschiffen oder aber auch auf
der Straße ist denn das wirklich eine
realistische und eine schnell umsetzbare
Lösung
Putin hat ja immer wieder die
Getreideexporte der Ukraine als Waffe in
diesem Krieg benutzt um sich ein Vorteil
zu schaffen insofern stellt sich seit
längerem schon die EU darauf ein
Alternativen zu suchen und sie hat sie
auch gefunden man nennt das ja im Europa
sprecht die sogenannten
solidaritätskorridore und diese
Korridore gehen durch unter anderem
Rumänien Polen und Slowenien da bringt
man das Kreide Getreide durch um es dann
in der Welt zu verteilen und Europa ist
da ziemlich erfolgreich gewesen etwa 60%
der Exporte der Ukraine von Getreide
geht durch Europa in die Welt aber jetzt
kommt eben das Problem 40% der Ukraine
Getreide Exporte geht halt immer noch
durch die Schwarze Meer und das ist ein
riesen Problem weil das wird man nicht
so schnell auffangen können man wird
jetzt weiter intensiv an diesen
solidaritätskorrektoren als an diesen
alternativen Strecken arbeiten aber das
dauert und insofern sagt man hier ein
bisschen Hoffnung hat man das werden am
Ende dieses Monats sich Putin mit den
afrikanischen Staaten trifft dass er
dann vielleicht ein Einsehen hat weil
das sind die Länder die vor allem vom
Hunger geplagt sind aber wie gesagt da
heißt es hier auch die Hoffnung stirbt
zuletzt sagt ultra vielen herzlichen
Dank nach Brüssel also wir haben es
gehört Infrastruktur lahmlegen
exportrouten schließen die Wirtschaft
angreifen das ist Russlands Kalkül zu
sehen auch daran dass laut kremme
Schiffe im Schwarzen Meer seit heute
Gegner Russland sind und dass der Hafen
in Odessa seit Tagen angegriffen wird
und genau dort ist Sarah Hassan
was kannst du uns denn über die
Situation vor Ort erzählen
die Menschen hier in Odessa die Leben in
zwei Welten tagsüber sind die Cafés gut
besucht man kann shoppen gehen die
Menschen gehen auch an den Stadtstrand
sie baden da in der Sonne manche sind
auch tapfer und gehen ins Wasser und
dann kommt die Nacht und damit auch das
Warten auf die russischen
Marschflugkörper die seit drei Nächten
hier eingeschlagen sind besonders
gefürchtet sind die Modelle mit geringer
Präzision und trotzdem mit 500 Kilogramm
Sprengstoff versehen ich war heute bei
einer Einschlagstelle und habe mit einer
Helferin gesprochen und sie sagte zu mir
sie kommt natürlich um zu helfen aber
für sie ist es auch die einzige Art und
mit ihren Erlebnissen und ihren Ängsten
umzugehen diese verarbeiten zu können
daran Hassan Sade war das live aus
Odessa vielen Dank auch für deine
Einschätzung ja der Krieg der bringt
Zerstörung wohin man nur schaut durch
Raketen durchbomben Panzer oder aber
auch durch Drohnen Anfang der Woche
haben diese ja für Schlagzeilen gesorgt
denn wasserdrohnen also unbemannte
Schiffe sollen die Brücke über die
Straße von Kersch angegriffen und
beschädigt haben also die Brücke die
Russland mit der Halbinsel Krim
verbindet der Einsatz von unbemannten
aber bewaffneten Drohnen steht ja immer
wieder zur Diskussion kritiker halten
sie für unverantwortliche
Killermaschinen Militärs dagegen sehen
sie als nützliche Unterstützung und die
Entwicklung geht und vermindert weiter
im Auftrag der Bundeswehr sollen nun
Drohnen Schwärme erprobt werden
inklusive künstlicher Intelligenz Jutta
sondern Wald
was Florian Seibel und seinem Team hier
auf dem Flugplatz Oberpfaffenhofen
gelingt ist für sie ein großer Schritt
zum ersten Mal Fliegen ihre
vektoraufklärungsdrohnen die sie auch an
die Ukraine liefern in einem Schwarm aus
auf Knopfdruck ausgestattet mit
Spezialkameras
infrarotsensorik und künstlicher
Intelligenz können Sie jede eigenständig
eine Mission erfüllen
dann auch miteinander kommunizieren und
sich gegenseitig quasi die Informationen
zukommen lassen intelligente
drohnenschwärme für die Bundeswehr zu
entwickeln die künftig im Gefecht
Kampfjets begleiten und unterstützen
daran forscht der bayerische
drohnenhersteller quantum systems
gemeinsam mit dem Rüstungsunternehmen
Airbus mit im Boot Experten von Spleen
Lab einem thüringischen Jungunternehmen
das sich auf maschinelles Lernen
spezialisiert hat
was drin das was unsere softair-lösung
kann ist in den Videodaten Objekte
unterschiedlicher Typen zum Beispiel
Fahrzeuge Personen also uniformierte
Personen Kinder Erwachsene diese
erkennen über die über das Video
verfolgen und dann auch entsprechend
klassifizieren das Wettrüsten um die
schwarmtechnologie hat längst begonnen
china hat dabei die Nase vorn auch
israel setzt intelligente
drohnenschwärme ein zur Aufklärung aber
auch für den Einsatz im Häuserkampf
bewaffnet und ausgerüstet mit k.i zur
Gesichtserkennung
drohnenschwärme sind kostengünstig
wartungsarm vielseitig einsetzbar und
verschaffen in hoher Geschwindigkeit
eine zielgenaue Übersicht über das
Einsatzgebiet das ist wirklich eine
Revolution diese Drohnen haben dass es
ihre wichtigste Neuerung auch eine
Schwarm Intelligenz jeder thronschwamm
jede einzelne Drohne gibt ihr Wissen
weiter an die nächste dro an den
nächsten Schwarm und das Gewissen geht
niemals verloren KI gesteuerte
drohnenschwärme sollen künftig auch beim
futurekombat-system kurz FKS eine Rolle
spielen Deutschland Frankreich und
Spanien entwickeln hier eine neue
Generation von modernen Kampfjets die im
Verbund mit unbemannten Drohnen agieren
Ihre Daten tauschen sie vernetzt aus
über eine sogenannte combat-cloud sie
werden nicht nur effektiver im Sinne der
Wirkung weil sich die Drohnen
gegenseitige Grenzen sie werden noch
effizienter weil sie geschickt die
Tätigkeiten aufeinander aufbauen können
und so können Sie am Ende des Tages den
Menschen besser entlasten je größer der
Drohnen Schwarm desto Autonummer ist der
unterwegs experten warnen vor den
ethischen und moralischen folgen sollte
der Mensch die Kontrolle verlieren und
KI übernehmen
man muss bedenken dass eine künstliche
Intelligenz die ja dann diese
drohnenschwärme steuert Menschen nicht
als Menschen sondern als Datenmuster
betrachtet und solche Systeme kennen zum
Beispiel auch kein Skrupel die KI
gesteuerten Drohnen die Florian Seibel
und sein Team bei Quantum derzeit
gemeinsam mit Airbus für die Bundeswehr
testen sind unbewaffnet bei diesem
Forschungsprojekt geht es in erster
Linie um schnellere Rettung und
präzisere Aufklärung im Schwarm ob sie
ihre Technologie in der Ukraine
einsetzen werden hängt davon ab wie
lange der Krieg dort noch dauert
wir machen in den Nachrichten weiter mit
zwei Ländern bei denen es gerade auch
zur Sache geht aber Hannah auf
diplomatischen Parkett ganz genau die
erneute Genehmigung einer Demonstration
in Stockholm bei der eine
Koranverbrennung geplant war hat eine
massive diplomatische Krise zwischen
Schweden und dem Irak ausgelöst die
irakische Regierung wie ist die
schwedische Botschafterin aus und rief
zudem ihren Geschäftsträger in Schweden
zurück zuvor hatten wütende irakische
Demonstranten die schwedische Botschaft
in Bagdad gestürmt und ein Feuer gelegt
bei der Demonstration in der
schwedischen Hauptstadt trat ein Mann
heute den Koran mit Füßen zu
angekündigten Verbrennung kam es jedoch
nicht
die werbeauftragte des Bundestags Högel
hat mehr Anstrengung beim Gewinn von
Rekruten angemahnt bis 2031 soll die
Bundeswehr um rund 21.000 Soldatinnen
und Soldaten auf 203.000 vergrößert
werden doch es sei sehr fraglich ob
dieses Ziel mit den bisherigen Maßnahmen
erreicht werden können er sagte Hügel
dem redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland es
brauche eine erhebliche Kraftanstrengung
um die Bundeswehr für junge Leute
attraktiver zu machen
mit einer Feierstunde wurde heute anders
gescheiterte Hitlerattentat vor 79
Jahren erinnert am 20 Juli 1944 hatten
Offiziere um Klaus Schenk Graf von
Staufenberg versucht dem Nazi-Regime mit
einem Sprengstoffanschlag auf Hitler ein
Ende zu setzen bei der
Gedenkveranstaltung im Berliner
bentlerblock wo Staufenberg und drei
weitere Männern nach der Tat erschossen
wurden forderte Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius mehr Wachsamkeit mit Blick auf
aktuelle extremistische Gefahren
Sicherheit Freiheit und Rechtsstaat
stünden unter Druck wie seit Jahrzehnten
nicht mehr
inmitten angespannter Beziehungen
zwischen Russland und den USA hat der
chinesische Präsident Ski den früheren
US-Außenminister und Sicherheitsberater
kissenger empfangen bei dem Treffen
forderte Ski Zitat neue Entscheidungen
für stabile Beziehungen zwischen beiden
Staaten zuvor hatte der inzwischen
hundertjährige Kissinger auch
teidigungsminister liege getroffen die
Verhandlungen des us-politikers waren in
den 1970er Jahren entscheidend für die
historische Annäherung zwischen China
und den USA
fast acht Monate nach dem Raub eines
keltischen Goldschatzes aus einem Museum
in Manching sitzen die vier Verdächtigen
nun in Untersuchungshaft laut dem
bayerischen Landeskriminalamt handelt es
sich wohl bei drei von ihnen um
Serientäter zudem wurde sehr
wahrscheinlich ein Teil der Beute
sichergestellt allerdings
zusammengeschmolzen in mehrere
Goldklumpen im November waren insgesamt
483 keltische Goldmünzen gestohlen
worden ihr Gold wert wird auf eine
viertel Millionen Euro beziffert
Ärztinnen Pflegekräfte IT-Spezialisten
Betriebswirte Personal im Hotel und
Gaststättenbereich wärmetechnikerinnen
Elektriker Handwerker ganz generell und
kurzum Fachkräfte in etlichen Branchen
und Bereichen fehlen und zwar seit
Jahren und seit Jahren gibt es
Bemühungen dem Problem entgegenzutreten
wie oft schon sind Politiker ins Ausland
gefahren um für Deutschland zu werben
oftmals hören diese dann dass die Hürden
zu hoch sein die Sprache zu kompliziert
die Bürokratie zur ausufern der
Familiennachzug zu problematisch das
dürfte sich mit dem beschlossenen
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
verbessern und so ist Arbeitsminister
Hubertus Heil wohl auch voller
Optimismus nach Indien gefahren dort
traf er tatsächlich auf Interesse aber
auch auf Skepsis lass bodensack
in Sachen Zuwanderung ist Hubertus Heil
so etwas wie ein Handlungsreisender nach
Afrika und Brasilien ist der
Arbeitsminister gerade auf dem indischen
Subkontinent unterwegs um das zu finden
was Deutschland dringend braucht
qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte im
wirtschaftsstarken Südindien trifft er
auf hoch motivierte Computerfachleute
und Ingenieurinnen die schon in wenigen
Monaten nach Deutschland reisen werden
meine erste Priorität war ein Land zu
finden wo ich und meine Familie
anerkannt werden und nicht
ausgeschlossen
es ist für mich leichter bei Ihnen einen
Job zu bekommen jeder Maschinenbauer
träumt davon nach Deutschland zu gehen
im letzten Dezember hatte die
Bundesregierung bereits ein Abkommen mit
Indien abgeschlossen um die
Arbeitsmigration zu erleichtern dazu
wurde vor wenigen Wochen das
Einwanderungsgesetz verabschiedet
dennoch Deutschland gut längst nicht
alleine um indische Fachkräfte es ist
allerdings nicht ganz klar wie sich die
Konkurrenzsituation gerade zu den
angelsächsischen Ländern entwickeln wird
denn wir sehen natürlich auch in Ländern
wie Großbritannien wie Australien Kanada
die USA das auch dort natürlich die
Nachfrage nach indischen Fachkräften
steigt aus Indien selber kommen klagen
über die deutsche Bürokratie ID energy
leitet seit Jahren ein Unternehmen das
indische Arbeitskräfte nach Deutschland
vermittelt die deutschen Behörden würden
an einfacher Arbeiter die gleichen
Anforderungen stellen wie ein Akademiker
es gibt zum Beispiel keine
einwanderungsregeln für unterschiedliche
Qualifikationen da würde ich mir mehr
Differenzierung wünschen es könnten viel
mehr in der nach Deutschland gehen wenn
man dieses Problem lösen würde
und das alles weiß der Arbeitsminister
und wird dennoch nicht müde für
Deutschland als arbeitsland zu werden
der Druck ist groß bis 2035 werden
deutschlandweit 7 Millionen Arbeitnehmer
aus dem Berufsleben ausscheiden
gleichzeitig drängen in Indien jeden
Monat eine Million junge Menschen auf
den Arbeitsmarkt
ist bekanntermaßen das größte Land der
Welt was die Bevölkerung betrifft die
größte Bevölkerungsdichte in diesem Land
indien hat zwar ein gutes
Wirtschaftswachstum aber nicht alle
ausgebildeten jungen Menschen finden
hier auch einen Job und die wollen wir
nach Deutschland einladen und zwar egal
ob sie akademisch gebildet sind oder
beruflich qualifiziert sind eine
Befürchtung allerdings haben viele Inder
in Deutschland mit Rassismus
konfrontiert zu werden
sicher gibt es viele Leute die uns nicht
haben wollen aber das ist ja nicht nur
in Deutschland so wir wissen dass uns
stellen uns darauf ein am Ende glaube
ich dass wir bei den meisten willkommen
sind
die fachkräfteeinwanderung entscheidet
mit über die Zukunftsfähigkeit
Deutschlands da kann es wohl auch nicht
schaden die lokalen Götter in Indien
milde zu stimmen
für Deutschland ist es natürlich ein
Gewinn wenn top ausgebildete Fachkräfte
zu uns kommen aber was bedeutet das für
die Länder aus denen diese Arbeitskräfte
dann gehen insbesondere wenn die jungen
gehen dem sogenannten brain drain will
jetzt Albanien einen Riegel vorschieben
nicht mit Anreizen sondern tatsächlich
mit einer Art Verbot Britta Hilpert über
ein Gesetz das noch heute Nacht im Eifer
fahren beschlossen werden soll und das
erstmal nur die trifft die jetzt Medizin
studieren
da kann es 40 Grad sein in Tirana bei so
einem Gesetz gehen die Medizin
Studierenden trotzdem auf die Straße es
soll ihnen die Abwanderung verbieten
sind die alamani studiert im dritten
Jahr nach ihrem Studium soll sie fünf
Jahre in Albanien arbeiten oder die
Kosten dafür zurückzahlen und 40.000
Euro der Regierungschef verlange
unmögliches
hat meine Pläne für die Zukunft geändert
ich wollte nicht eigentlich im Ausland
spezialisieren aber mit dem Gesetz ist
mir das praktisch verboten albanien hat
Europas geringste Ärzte dich der
besonders in der Provinz während der
Pandemie hatte Albanien auch deshalb mit
die höchste Übersterblichkeit es fehlt
an moderner Ausrüstung der
Altersdurchschnitt der Ärzte ist hoch
und überall fehlt es ein Fachärzten wie
Gynäkologen bis zu zwei Drittel der
Mediziner geht nach dem Studium ins
Ausland
finanziert das Studium nicht für das
deutsche Gesundheitssystem sagte
Regierungschef Rama schon im März es ist
an der Zeit dass alle Länder sich mit
dem Problem befassen
doch so eingesetzt ist nicht das
richtige Mittel meint migrationexperte
Thomas Liebig zum einen besteht die
Befürchtung dass sich in Albanien
weniger Personen für eine Ausbildung im
Gesundheitssystem entscheiden
und darüber hinaus besteht die Gefahr
dass diejenigen die ohnehin abwandern
wollten das tun werden ohne diese
Gebühren zu bezahlen und danach nachher
einfach nicht wieder nach Albanien
zurückkehren schon Jens Spahn fuhr auf
Werbetour auf den Balkan seit Jahren
wird Deutschland hier um die besten
Kräfte deutschland braucht sie und Zeit
bis zu drei Mal so viel doch das Gehalt
ist nur ein Faktor meint der Arzt
die albanische Regierung hätte längst
agieren müssen
natürlich muss das Gehalt besser werden
aber auch die Weiterbildung die
Perspektiven und die gesellschaftliche
Anerkennung
in Albaniens Notaufnahmen ist das
gelungen für andere Bereiche im
Gesundheitssystem fehlen Geld und Ärzte
eine Länder übergreifende
ausbildungspartnerschaft mit
Kostenteilung könnte da helfen meint
Thomas Liebig wir unterstützt
Deutschland die Ausbildung vor Ort ein
Teil der Person kommt dann auch nach
Deutschland und ein anderer Teil wird im
Ursprungsland in dem Falle Albanien
bleiben mit ein paar Jahren arbeite im
Ausland hätte sie eine bessere Ärztin
werden können mein Cindy alamani daraus
wird nichts und das hilft wieder ihr
noch dem deutschen noch dem albanischen
Gesundheitssystem
so und wir stellen uns jetzt die Frage
hilft grüner Stahl bei der
Transformation zu mehr
Klimafreundlichkeit jedenfalls hannah
ist dafür der Weg jetzt erstmal frei
gemacht der Industriekonzern
thyssenKrupp will nämlich künftig
klimafreundlichen Stahl produzieren und
seit heute ist klar Deutschland und das
Land Nordrhein-Westfalen dürfen dieses
Vorhaben mit bis zu 2 Milliarden Euro
subventionieren die EU-Kommission hat
der Förderung zugestimmt Frank Bethmann
was bedeutet dieser Schritt genau der
konkret das eben ThyssenKrupp jetzt in
Duisburg wo rund 13.000 Menschen
arbeiten eine Großanlage zur Herstellung
von grünen Stahl bauen kann eine
sogenannte
direktreduktionsanlage sie soll
anfänglich noch mit Erdgas später mit
klimaneutral erzeugten Wasserstoff
betrieben werden die Gesamtanlage soll
Ende 2026 in Betrieb gehen weitere
Stahlproduzenten wollen in Deutschland
solche Anlagen bauen auch die Firma
Salzgitter die ebenfalls Fördermittel
bekommt
eigentlich wirklich so grün
ja grün ist er nur wenn wirklich der
Wasserstoff mit dem er produziert wird
grün ist sprich aus regenerativen
Quellen gewonnen wird grüner Wasserstoff
kommt derzeit aber noch nicht zum
Einsatz deswegen wird ein Großteil der
Beihilfen jetzt auch nicht für den Bau
der Anlagen gewährt den Löwenanteil der
Zuschüsse den gibt es um die Mehrkosten
zu decken wenn die Anlage in Betrieb
geht und diese Mehrkosten entstehen weil
eben die Beschaffung und Nutzung von
diesem grünen Wasserstoff erheblich
teurer ist da die Stahlproduktion aber
besonders energieintensiv ist lässt sich
hier eben auch besonders viel CO2
einsparen mit 58 Millionen Tonnen wird
gerechnet die über die gesamte
Lebensdauer der Anlage nicht mehr in die
Luft geblasen werden vielen Dank für
diese Einordnung
wer Bahn fährt statt zu fliegen der muss
in Europa in den meisten Fällen tiefer
in die Tasche greifen zu diesem Ergebnis
kommt eine Untersuchung der
Umweltorganisation Greenpeace die
europaweit Ticketpreise verglichen hat
und zwar auf mehr als 100 Strecken in
71% der Fälle sei die Bahn teurer als
das Flugzeug greenpeace forderte mit
Blick auf die Ergebnisse eine
europaweite Kerosinsteuer von 50 Cent
pro Liter
nach der massiven Hitze in Norditalien
und auf dem Balkan folgten in der Nacht
schwere Unwetter dabei wurden mindestens
sechs Menschen getötet um zahlreiche
verletzt in Kroatiens Hauptstadt Zagreb
er schlugen umstürzende Bäume laut
gehört Angaben zwei Männer Straßen
wurden überflutet und blockiert auch ein
Baukran kippte um der Kranführer wurde
verletzt
in Brandenburg und im Süden Berlins
suchen Polizei und Feuerwehr noch immer
mit einem Großaufgebot nach einer
freilaufenden Raubkatze möglicherweise
einer Löwin der Hinweis auf das Wildtier
erreichte die Polizei in der Nacht ein
Video aus kleinen magno in Brandenburg
zeigt mutmaßlich eine Großkatze zwischen
Bäumen und Büschen mit Drohnen
Hubschraubern und Wärmebildkameras
suchen die Einsatzkräfte nach dem Tier
unterstützt von Tierärzten und Jägern
Anwohner sind aufgerufen zu Hause zu
bleiben woher das Tier stammt ist bisher
nicht bekannt
ein Novum nach dem anderen bietet die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft der Frauen
erstmals gibt es zwei ausrichterländer
zu dem sind erstmals insgesamt 32 Länder
mit dabei und gut das ist jetzt nicht
ganz neu aber vielleicht schon
ungewöhnlich die Eröffnungsfeier war
auffallend kurz und knackig kurz und
knackig soll die WM in Australien und
Neuseeland für das deutsche Team
natürlich nicht werden nach 2003
2007 soll dann endlich mal wieder ein
WM-Titel her heute mussten aber erst
einmal die Gastgeberinnen ran und da
erwischen beide einen Traumstart die
Fans also best gelaunt und ausgelassen
dabei saß im Vorfeld nicht unbedingt
danach aus denn es kam zu einer
Schießerei Heiko Klasen mit dem
doppelten Blick auf Australien und
Neuseeland
zwei Gastgeberländer 2 Eröffnungsfeiern
und tatsächlich diese Shows gleich
doppelt gut in Auckland und Sydney bunt
soll sie werden diese neunte
Frauenfußball-Weltmeisterschaft
kurzweilig und unterhaltsam das zentrale
Thema gleich zu Beginn die kulturelle
Identität das kulturelle Erbe der
Gastgeber lange Zeit vergessen und
verdrängt die Vertreter der
neuseeländischen Maori und der indigenen
Völker Australiens hier stehen Sie im
Mittelpunkt
unbeschwert und fröhlich ein
farbenfrohes Fußballfest auf dass ich
gleich zu Beginn ein dunkler Schatten
wirft im Zentrum der neuseeländischen
Hauptstadt unweit der Fanmeile erschießt
noch vor der Eröffnungsfeier ein
Amokläufer zwei Menschen auch der
Schütze selbst sehr Tod berichtet später
die Polizei in Auckland es soll sich um
einen Einzeltäter Handeln es wurde kein
polit Coaches oder ideologisches Motiv
festgestellt es besteht daher kein
Risiko für die nationale Sicherheit
dennoch rückt der Fußball erstmal in den
Hintergrund angesichts solcher Bilder
und auch im dfb-quartier herrscht
Betroffenheit natürlich sind solche
Nachrichten immer erst mal Schock aber
wir fühlen uns auf jeden Fall sicher mit
unseren Sicherheitsbeauftragten
das WM-Turnier startet mit einer
Schweigeminute ein kurzes Innehalten und
gedenken bevor der Fußball wieder voll
und ganz in den Vordergrund rückt rein
sportlich gesehen kann es für die
Gastgeberinnen allerdings gar nicht
besser anfangen zunächst gewinnt
ziemlich überraschend Neuseeland gegen
Norwegen mit eins zu null dieses Tor von
wirkensen also das erste bei dieser
Weltmeisterschaft
anschließend schlägt auch Australien
Irland mit 1:0 und das vor mehr als
75.000 Zuschauern die Euphorie kennt
keine Grenzen und viele träumen hier
schon vom WM Triumph sind damit aber
nicht allein auch im deutschen Quartier
sind sie nämlich durchaus optimistisch
ich glaube wir sind wirklich gerade auf
einem sehr guten Stand haben noch ein
paar Tage die wir auch benötigen das ist
auch klar aber ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass wir wenn es losgeht wenn wir
das erste Spiel dann auch haben da sein
werden am Montag geht's los dann ist es
soweit der erste Gegner für das deutsche
Team Marokko
tja und die bessere Mannschaft soll
natürlich gewinnen doch wie ist es wenn
es um streiten geht gewinnt der bessere
der lautere der der die besten Argumente
hat oder wollen wir eh nur noch in
unserer Meinung bestätigt werden das ist
jetzt Thema bei Maybrit Illner Freiheit
nur für meine Meinung müssen wir wieder
streiten lernen ja und dann noch der
Hinweis auf unser heute journal Update
gegen 0 Uhr 30 mit Christopher Wehrmann
das war es von uns beiden morgen steht
hier wieder Christian Sievers machen sie
es gut wo auch immer sie sind tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend auch heute war es rund um
das Mittelmeer wie der brütend heißt mit
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 33 und 48
Grad und auch das Mittelmeer ist zurzeit
sehr warm die Wassertemperaturen liegen
zwischen 27 und 29 Grad wenn sie jetzt
gerade Reisen planen dann interessiert
Sie vielleicht das Wetter der nächsten
Tage über Nord und Westeuropa müssen sie
immer wieder mit Tiefs rechnen also mit
kräftigen Regenfällen zum Teil sogar mit
Sturm in Südeuropa dagegen dominiert
nach wie vor Sonnenschein und Hitze viel
angenehme ist das Wetter bei uns heute
Nacht es ist meist stark bewölkt auch an
der Küste gibt's noch einige Gewitter
und spätestens in der zweiten
Nachthälfte setzt dann von Westen Regen
ein die Temperaturen sinken auf 16 Grad
im Rhein-Main-Gebiet und bis 9 Grad an
der Trave oder in der Uckermark und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen an
den Küsten von Nord und Ostsee etwa
genauso wie die Wassertemperaturen
nämlich bei 18 bis 19 Grad sonst werden
20 bis 26 Grad erreicht und das wird ein
sehr wechselhafter Freitag immer wieder
gibt es Regenschauer oder kurze Gewitter
das muss nicht jeden treffen könnte aber
jeden treffen und zwischendurch werden
sie auch mal die Sonne zu Gesicht
bekommen bei westvet am Samstag gibt es
einen Streifen hier von der Ostseeküste
bis zum Oberrhein wo es häufig
freundlich ist von Nordwesten ziehen
schon neue Schauer und Gewitter heran
und am Nachmittag gibt es dann auch am
Alpenrand Gewitter der Sonntag wird dann
im Norden deutlich regnerischer als im
Süden und wechselhaft startet die neue
Woche guten Abend